you wear underwear under your bathing
suit yeah doesn't everybody ah if it
isn't another Groundhog Day type movie
Palm Springs who lose latest original
starring Andy Samberg and Cristin
Milioti is actually pretty good I mean
it's no masterpiece that is happy
deathday too in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into Palm Springs
explaining its time loops and what
exactly happened in that ending but
before we get stuck in an infinite time
loop make sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more breakdowns theories and deep dives
Palm Springs is the story of Niles a man
forced to live the same day over and
over again unlike movies like Groundhog
Day which take time for the protagonist
to get into their loop Palm Springs
focuses on Niles who has already lived
this day hundreds if not thousands of
times
he's complacent thinks life is
meaningless and has given in that this
is his fate the only way to really live
in this is to embrace the fact that
nothing matters I think your best bet is
just to learn how to suffer existence
Niles has to relive the wedding of his
girlfriend's best friend's wedding over
and over a wedding which takes place
November 9th which coincidentally is the
same day Albert Einstein received the
Nobel Prize for his work on theoretical
physics for Niles this is a day like any
other
he's completely memorized where everyone
on the dance floor will be to try to woo
Sarah the bride's sister and Sarah like
Niles is extremely flawed
she believes love doesn't exist in that
marriage is [ __ ] nobody can stand
the idea of being alone so we buy into
this pageantry celebrates so it makes
sense that the man who thinks life is
meaningless and the woman who believes
love doesn't exist to get stuck in a
time loop together for all eternity you
see the night they're about to get it on
Niles is attacked by a man we'll come to
know as Roy Roy is also stuck in the
loop in
fact it was Niles who brought Roy to the
mysterious time-loop cave one night
during a coke induced bender oh yeah
there's this cave that has a portal in
it that traps people in the time loop
the problem is there doesn't seem to be
a way to end the loop if you go into the
portal you just wake up and start the
day over again but if you don't go into
it you'll wake up and start the day over
anyway there's no escape
Roy holds Niles responsible for getting
trapped in this loop and often comes
looking for him to torture he believes
marriage is a bottomless pit but as
we'll find out later he lets go of his
hatred towards Niles and embraces his
life
hopefully Niles can learn that he can
change too what happened to marriage
being a bottomless pit of sorrow things
change you know I already changed over
the course of the film Niles and Sarah
fall in love go on adventures and just
have fun with the card they've been
dealt we learned that Sarah had sex with
her sister's fiance the day before the
wedding that pain of the terrible things
she's done eats away at her and she
takes it out on Niles in retaliation he
tells her he had sex with her multiple
times in previous loops before she got
stuck this is the classic romantic
comedy structure we're about
three-quarters of the way through the
movie [ __ ] hits the fin and it looks
like our couple might not make it
through at all Niles wakes up after
their fight and for weeks months years
we actually don't know how long because
the loop keeps repeating he can't find
Sarah she's gone on her own adventure to
find a way to break the loop spending
most of her time reading about quantum
physics eventually she finds out that
the loop has a brief 3.2 second window
where one can propel themselves out
using explosives of course and she knows
this could work since she experiments on
a go to the next day is no longer in her
loop it didn't reappear so it must have
gone someplace else
Sara tells Niles the good news but he
doesn't want to leave don't want to
leave there's a difference oh yeah
what's the difference I want to stay
with you she wants to go he wants to
stay and ultimately she decides to go
without him spending her final night
giving a heartfelt speech to her sister
at her wedding but there's one scene
that really confused me and I'm
wondering if any of you who watched it
caught it get ready to put on your
tinfoil hat after Sarah gives her
each her grandmother comes up to her and
tells her how great it was but watch
this and pay close attention to Sara's
reaction well I suppose now that you'll
be going soon good luck I suppose now
that you'll be going soon
how does Nana know here that she's
leaving tonight is she referring to her
leaving the party I know this is gonna
sound bonkers but it almost made me
think that Nana is part of the loop too
after all in this loop she gets to live
over and over again with the ones she
loves if she were to go back well she's
old and who knows how much time she has
left am I crazy let me know what you
think in the comments below
at the same time Niles is moping at the
bar lament in losing the love of his
life when he's given some great advice
from Darla whatever you're after it
ain't here he rushes to Sarah and
professes his love
I'd rather die with you than live in
this world without you Niles has gone
from thinking life is meaningless to
thinking life is meaningless without her
sara has gone from believing love as a
fairy tale to knowing that true love can
exist in case I don't see you again
they head into the portal and detonate
the explosives when we next find them
floating in a pool together and there's
a brief moment of wondering whether or
not their plan worked
Niles says he should go pick up his dog
now considering the plan did indeed work
as the owners of the home they've
crashed arrived it's november 10th and
the day has gone forward and they've
successfully broken from the loop but
more importantly they broken their
preconceived notions of love and
existence through their love they've
realized life is worth living the camera
pants upward to reveal in the distance a
pack of brontosauruses brontosaurus a
nod back to the night they were high on
mushrooms
I imagine some people may interpret this
as them still in some weird alternate
reality but I personally wouldn't go
that far it's just a fun way to end the
movie however there is one final scene
shortly after the credits which lets us
know what happened to Roy he is still in
the loop and at the wedding goes to
Niles telling him that Sarah's theory
about getting out of the loop is crazy
but it just might work
Niles however has no idea who he is
thereby letting Roy know that Sarah's
plan worked and that he and Sarah made
it out of the loop overall I gotta say I
enjoyed Palm Springs Andy Samberg and
Cristin Milioti have great chemistry and
it was a fun twist on a gimmick that has
been overdone thanks everyone for
watching make sure to LIKE and subscribe
and leave a comment below for more bat
takes you can follow me on twitter at
pings story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much